[Musique]
bonjour a tous rêvé de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo le meilleur de la semaine
politique et parlementaire
bonjour au rayonnement de ses méninges
en riant il cette semaine pour refaire
la semaine avec nous nous recevons
stephen peu bonjour merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes le député communiste de
seine saint denis nous allons donc
refaire la semaine avec vous et on
commence avec un rapport qui a fait du
bruit à l'assemblée un député de la
majorité proposé de fusionner quotient
familial et allocations familiales ce
qui n'a pas été du goût de son co
rapporteurs députés les républicains le
rapport est donc enterrée mais le débat
sur la politique familiale rouvert à
l'assemblée nationale l'examen du projet
de loi de programmation militaire
objectif faire passer le budget des
armées de 34 milliards à 50 milliards
et puis au menu de la séance au sénat
l'examen d'une proposition de loi sur
les données personnelles qui renforce
les pouvoirs de contrôle de la
commission nationale informatique et
libertés elle s'est donc un rapport qui
a mis le feu aux poudres
retour sur ce tollé sur la politique
familiale à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors quel avenir pour le quotient
familial dans son rapport un député de
la république en marche proposé de le
fusionner avec les allocations
familiales une ligne rouge pour la
droite le co-rapporteur les républicains
a refusé de signer ce rapport il est
donc enterrée à la politique familiale a
mis en ébullition les bancs de
l'hémicycle elle le riz soit chaud c'est
un rapport en sursis qui risque de ne
jamais voir le jour
et pour cause les co rapporteurs du
texte n'arrive pas à se mettre d'accord
d'un côté guillaume chiche le député de
la majorité proposent que le quotient
familial qui réduit l'impôt sur le
revenu des familles imposables soit
remplacé par des allocations à toutes
les familles dès le premier enfant de
l'autre
gilles lurton le député les républicains
refusent de franchir ce qui est pour lui
une ligne rouge pour moi le quotient
familial c'est le fondement de notre
politique familiale c'est ce qu'il veut
que une famille avec enfants ne voient
pas sûr niveau de vie diminuer par
rapport à une famille qui n'a pas d'hier
la proposition a provoqué un tollé sur
les bancs de la droite
[Applaudissements]
pourtant guillaume chiche conteste les
reproches des députés les républicains
eux aujourd'hui parlent d'une opposition
à la suppression du quotient familial
moi j'appelle à une transformation et
des allocations familiales et du
quotient familial et des accès aux
services publics notamment aux
établissements d'accueil de jeunes
enfants
devant l'agitation de l'opposition
olivier ferrand précise la position de
la majorité sur le sujet il n'y a pas de
suppression du quotient familial c'est
écrit absolument nulle part mais pas de
proposition en ce sens il n'y a pas de
projet de loi pas de proposition
parlementaire de loi est comme
rapporteur général du budget de la sécu
je serais au courant s'il y avait une
telle proposition qui était à l'étude
donc on est vraiment dans quelque chose
de très virtuel je pense que ça va
rester pour un moment quelque chose
d'assez virtuel le texte contient
d'autres pistes moins polémique comme le
versement de la prime de naissance avant
l'accouchement et non après ou encore la
création de places en crèche
stéphane plus est ce que vous vous
déplorez ce rapport soit intéresse que
c'était une bonne idée de fusionner
quotient familial allocations familiales
alors d'abord je pense que c'était une
très mauvaise idée
d'abord c'est curieux devant ya un
problème de méthode la majorité se
réfère souvent au programme du président
20 du candidat macron qui s'applique
pour le coup ce sujet n'était absolument
pas dans le programme du candidat macro
il est né comme ça dans la tête d'un
député même pas discuter avec son co
rapporteur dont la méthode est pas trés
pas très correct et puis en plus un
grand cafouillage dans la majorité vous
en avez entendu la ministre qui dément
les propos du rapporteur un autre député
président d'une commission qui dément
également le propos du rapporteur d'un
grand cafouillage dans dans la majorité
mais pour revenir sur le fond c'est une
mauvaise idée parce que il ya deux
choses dans la politique familiale il ya
le quotient familial qui permet d'avoir
un abattement de
2 sur les impôts et quelles que soient
ses revenus mais j'ai envie de dire en
fonction on considérer que l'arrivée
d'un enfant dans une famille quelles que
soient ses revenus ne peut pas ne doit
pas pouvoir d'achat c'est pour
encourager une politique nataliste et
notre pays tiers aussi de sa démographie
plus positif que d'autres pays européens
une force
donc je pense que l'universalité du
quotient familial est une bonne chose il
faut différencier politique familiale et
politique sociale
bien sûr parce que il faut conserver de
l'universalité du quotient familial
et puis par ailleurs ça a été ça a été
évoqué dans le reportage
il ya beaucoup à faire sur les places en
crèche dans notre pays où il ya
seulement 30 % de demandes qui sont
couvertes alors que c'est un outil aussi
une nécessité il faut accélérer la
scolarisation des enfants à partir de
l'âge de deux ans je suis dans un
département où seulement 4 % des moins
de trois ans sont scolarisés en
maternelle ce qu'est le département la
seine saint denis qui a le plus faible
taux de scolarisation des enfants de
moins de 3 ans il ya beaucoup de choses
à faire aussi soit la revalorisation des
allocations familiales notamment pour
les familles des plus modestes mais on
ne peut pas il ya toujours un piège avec
ce gouvernement ils font un peu la même
chose sur les cotisations sociales
c'est d'ailleurs qu'on touche à des
principes universels la sécurité sociale
le quotient familial pour un pour les
familles et puis par ailleurs la
redistribution pour aider les plus
modestes de notre pays c'est deux choses
différentes dans l'histoire de notre
politique mais si on vous entend bien il
faut tout de même rouvrir le débat sur
la politique familiale
quand on sait qu'un enfant sur cinq est
touché par la pauvreté aujourd'hui en
france ben oui mais il faut d'abord
s'attaquer à la pauvreté parce que si
vous voulez un enfant qui subit la
pauvreté je vous parle d'un territoire
la seine-saint-denis où c'est beaucoup
plus qu'un enfant sur cinq c'est d'abord
des enfants qui naissent dans une
famille où les parents sont touchées par
la pauvreté par l'absence de travail par
la précarisation de l'emploi donc on
peut pas avoir d'un côté toute une série
de lois qui précarisent un peu plus le
salariat qui diminue
les ressources des familles modestes qui
amputent le pouvoir d'achat des plus
pauvres qui va faire la chasse aux
chômeurs comme on l'a vu aussi cette
semaine et en même temps constaté qu'il
ya des enfants qui sont dans la
difficulté et donc on sait que la
politique familiale aujourd'hui remplie
vraiment ses objectifs bon d'abord la
démographie dans notre pays je les dis
est positive et plus positif que dans
d'autres pays européens
moi je pense que il faut renforcer les
aides
à travers les allocations familiales ce
qui est autre chose que c'est donc sur
les allocations familiales qu'il faut
que les allocations et l'accompagnement
de l'arrivée de l'enfant dans la famille
c'est à dire les congés maternité les
congés paternité qui doivent être plus
long les places en crèche augmenté il
faut je pense un grand plan de création
de places en crèche dans dans ce pays
c'est à la fois de l'emploi et et puis
des choses positives aussi pour
l'insertion de l'enfant parce qu'un
enfant
plus l'enfant est dans une situation
précaire ise ou pauvre plus il est à la
porte des infrastructures il apporte des
crèches il à la porte des écoles avant
trois ans donc c'est aussi ça qui
contribuent à un cafouillage au sein de
la majorité à ce que tout de même
origine vous réjouissez du fait que
l'aide sociale de cette majorité veulent
se faire entendre
oui mais je là pour le coup oui je me
réjouis bien évidemment qui est des
députés dans la majorité de plus en plus
qui expriment de la réserve sur un
gouvernement qui est quand même un
gouvernement très unilatérale en faveur
des plus riches de ce pays mais qui
expriment des de la réserve ou un doute
bon ça c'est tout une bonne chose mais
je suppose heures pour le coup que cette
proposition était une proposition on
pourrait qualifier venant de l'aide
sociale je pense que lé plus tôt c'est
plutôt une proposition amont de mon
point de vue assez irréfléchie et avec
une majorité qui est on l'a souvent dit
un peu hors sol et un peu dépourvus de
culture politique et historique
on croit pouvoir s'affranchir de
vieilles lunes et alors que c'est des
fondements du pacte social dans notre
pays on passe à un autre sujet un
stéphane peu le budget des armées en
hausse c'était la promesse de la loi de
programmation militaire débattu cette
semaine à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les députés examinent et donc le projet
de loi de programmation militaire 2019
2025 un plan ambitieux de les efforts
sont importants selon la ministre
désarmés pour que le budget de la
défense représente 2% du pib en 2025
loris baz chauffe près de 300 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2025
c'est la promesse du gouvernement pour
les armes et la hausse sera progressive
de 34 milliards d'euros cette année le
budget de la défense augmentera de 1
milliard 700 millions d'euros par an
entre 2019 et 2022
puis de 3 milliards d'euros par an entre
2023 et 2025
objectif d'ici sept ans atteindre un
budget équivalent à 2% du pib un niveau
fixé par les membres de l'otan les
conditions de vie les conditions de
travail d'exécution des missions de nos
soldats sont tout à fait prioritaire
premières mesures du projet de loi
le renforcement des moyens humains avec
la création de 6000 postes civils et
militaires le renseignement concentrera
un quart des recrutements deuxième
chantier la modernisation des moyens
matériels
le renouvellement sera accélérée avec
désarmement livrer plus tôt et en plus
grand nombre
troisième axe du texte la consolidation
de la dissuasion nucléaire de la france
25 milliards d'euros entre 2019 et 2023
c est fort succès à 10 ans de réductions
d'effectifs et de diminution des crédits
aux armées
l'année dernière la baisse de 850
millions d'euros du budget avait conduit
à la démission du chef d'état major des
armées pierre de villiers et stéphane
peu le temps des sacrifices est il
révolu comme le déclarait florence parly
en ouverture des débats
d'abord on l'espère mais je constate
quand même il s'est pas le premier
budget où on constate cela c'est que
l'essentiel des efforts sont pour le
quinquennat prochain à partir de 2020 à
partir de 2023 milliards par an de
hausse contre 1,7 milliard à l'arrivée
donc c'est toujours un peu c'est bon
c'est bon on a toujours un peu de doutes
quant au renvoi
sur la sincérité de bien sûr c'est un
peu comme la faim dans un tout autre
domaine
je les fais observer dans l'hémicycle
sur la politique de la ville et de la
rénovation des quartiers on renvoie
l'essentiel de l'effort budgétaire après
2022 c'est à dire pour le quinquennat la
prob mon prochain
bon moi j'aime bien en politique les
gens qui assument leur mission et leur
engagement pour la période dans laquelle
ils sont aux affaires et elle ne pas
trop renvoyé à plus tard ce qu'on peut
faire aujourd'hui ça c'est la première
observation à la deuxième où on mélange
beaucoup de choses dans ce budget
l'essentiel de l'effort va l'être sur la
dissuasion nucléaire
les efforts sur les moyens matériels
d'une armée qui je le rappelle il ya eu
beaucoup de reportages et beaucoup de
témoignages de deux gradés sont est une
arme est en voie de clochardisation
quand vous voyez dans quel état
matériels sont les soldats qui sont sur
des opérations extérieures ou même ici
en france qu'on vous allez visiter un
sous marin que vous voyez l'état de
délabrement de nos navires de notre
flotte de nos moyens matériels là là là
là je ne parle même pas des des
logiciels de paye qui n'arrive pas à
fonctionner pour payer nos soldats et
pour payer les donc vous nous dites que
cet effort budgétaire ne va pas servir
finalement au quotidien des militaires
c'est la principale remarque on en a
plusieurs mais la principale remarque
sur les moyens dans cette loi de
programmation militaire c'est de dire
l'essentiel est absorbée par une
dissuasion nucléaire que nous contestons
comme étant la l'investissement majeur
efficace
s'agissant qu'en plus la loi de la
dissuasion nucléaire il ya aucune
transparence nous avons demandé un peu
plus de transparence sur ou à laisser 25
milliards pour pour quoi faire et puis
on voit bien que la dissuasion nucléaire
c'est quand même une obligation qui nous
est faite de part notre appartenance à
l'otan plutôt que pour obéir à une
politique de la france engagée sur un
tas d'une série de théâtre d'opérations
de manière légitime puisque nous avons
approuvé la plupart de ses interventions
donc c'est pas le fait que c'est quand
même un bon début documenter le
des armes et qui jusqu'à maintenant
étaient plutôt en baisse oui mais bien
sûr mais vers où va l'argent appuyé
enfin quand même une observation sur
l'otan qu'est ce que notre pays fait
encore dans une organisation où nous
côtoyons à la fois monsieur trump est la
politique qui est la sienne qui je
l'espère n'a rien à voir avec eux ce que
défendent la france du point de vue de
la politique de défense et monsieur
erdogan qui vient de massacrer les
kurdes qui avaient été nos alliés contre
des ch ou alors nous pensons qu'il faut
sortir de l'otan réaffirmé
l'indépendance de la france s'oriente et
pourquoi pas et nous l'avons dit dans
l'hémicycle vers une perspective d'une
défense européenne mais surtout pas en
étant arrivé à cette organisation qui
nous impose des choix pour notre
politique de défense et qui ne
correspondent pas aux intérêts d'une
très longue passe est votre à contre
cette loi et doit donc qui sera soumise
au vote la semaine prochaine à
l'assemblée le sénat lui a adopté le
projet de loi sur la protection des
données personnelles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le sénat a modifié de nombreux points de
cette proposition de loi déjà adopté par
l'assemblée nationale un texte qui
renforce les pouvoirs de la commission
nationale informatique et libertés mais
qui doit aussi mieux protéger les
français résumé de la séance avec
quentin calme mais c'est désormais
officiel dès mai 2010huit toutes nos
données personnelles sur internet seront
mieux protégés mercredi le sénat a
adopté les mesures d'un nouveau
règlement européen qui vient compléter
les mesures créée en 1978 dans la loi
informatique et libertés avec un
meilleur encadrement une plus grande
responsabilité pour tous ceux qui
collectent ces données personnelles même
lorsqu'il s'agit d'entreprises résidant
à l'étranger
la france a pris une part très active
dans les négociations européennes afin
de maintenir et de promouvoir son modèle
de contrôle et de protection qui
constitue encore aujourd'hui une
référence en europe et dans le monde
parmi les mesures de ce projet de loi la
création d'une majorité numérique c'est
à dire d'un seuil d'âge en dessous
duquel les adolescents devront tenir une
autorisation parentale avant de
s'inscrire sur les réseaux sociaux
votez à 15 ans par les députés les
sénateurs ont choisi 16 ans des
sénateurs qui sur certains sujets se
sont montrés particulièrement critique
envers le gouvernement
notre commission a tenu à répondre aux
attentes et aux vives inquiétudes des
collectivités territoriales ce sont les
grandes absentes du projet de loi elles
sont pourtant de la plus petite à la
plus grande
tout est absolument tout concernés par
les dispositions du règlement
c'est donc là un des apports du sénat
les collectivités locales seront mieux
accompagner les sénateurs qui ont
également imposer la transparence des
algorithmes de l'administration comme
sur la plateforme parcours sub par
exemple enfin la haute assemblée a voté
la création d'un label pour les objets
connectés vertueux en matière de
protection des données
dans quelques mois nous données
personnelles seront donc mieux protégés
si les entreprises récoltant ces
informations ne jouaient pas le jeu
elle pourrait faire face à des amendes
extrêmement lourdes jusqu'à 4% du
chiffre d'affaires mondial de ces géants
de l'internet
stéphane que vous avez travaillez vous
sur ce texte à l'assemblée nationale le
sénat ya apporté de nombreuses
modifications que
c'est vous des modifications de la haute
assemblée il y en a au moins deux qui
sont positives qu'on avait nous même
suggéré dans le débat parlementaire un
c'est de renforcer les moyens pour les
collectivités locales d'être co co
acteur de cette loi puisqu'il ya
beaucoup de choses aujourd'hui dans la
numérisation de l'administration qui
passe par les zones et les collectivités
locales et c'est normal de les
accompagner dans cette proposition du
sénat est plutôt positive
et puis la transparence des algorithmes
pour prendre des mesures administratives
alors c'est un pas en avant ce que cette
proposition du sénat mais pour autant ce
n'est pas suffisant parce que nous nous
avions déposé un amendement pour essayer
de faire en sorte qu'il ne puisse pas
aidé à vous d'avoir à avoir
d'algorithmes pour les administrations
qui échappe à la correction humaine
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
d'ailleurs posé une question écrite au
gouvernement sur le sujet il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de dysfonctionnements dans les
administrations de par une volonté de
numériser avec des algorithmes sur
lesquels on ne peut plus intervenir une
fois qu'ils sont mis en place il ya
aujourd'hui 110 mille cartes grises qui
n'arrive pas être délivré des permis de
conduire avec des listes de d'attendre
tout ça est très concret et donc la
sécurité sociale et la caisse que les
caisses primaires d'assurance maladie
c'est un une numérisation avec des
algorithmes qui produisent des
catastrophes avec des non remboursements
en cascade donc tout ça dysfonctionne
et comme en plus on a des algorithmes
qui ne peuvent pas être corrigé par part
par l'intervention humaine et que
d'autre part on en profite pour
supprimer des pans entiers de service
public est en contact avec les
administrés et ben il sent ressortent de
graves dysfonctionnements
j'ai cité descartes les allées permis de
conduire et la caisse primaire
d'assurance-maladie montpeul l'étendre
sur toute une autre série de services et
puis enfin intentions on renforce la
cnil mais en même temps on à la loi
informatique et libertés qui date de 60
18 donc il doit être bien évidemment
modifier adapter mais le gouvernement à
travers cette cette loi autorise à
revoir dans les mois qui viennent la loi
informatique et libertés par voie
d'ordonnancé
or quand on touche à une loi sur les
libertés fondamentales
on ne doit pas légiférer par ordonnance
donc c'est un autre désaccord assez fort
qu'on a avec cette loi sur les données
personnelles qui globalement est plus
positive et protège davantage les
français avec des limites et justement
est-ce que les données personnelles des
françaises seront mieux protégés à
l'avenir ils seront mieux protégés oui
ça c'est sûr avec des amendes et des
sanctions plus fortes vous avez vu cette
semaine il ya eu un en sort dallaire qui
a dévoilé comment 50 millions
d'américains de profil facebook
américains avaient été compilés pour
fabriquer des profils électoraux pour la
campagne de donald trump ça ne pourrait
pas venir
normalement ça ne pouvait avec cette
fois ça rend beaucoup plus difficile et
ce type de manoeuvre mais pour autant ne
va pas assez loin sur la dimension
commerciale par exemple vous pouvez
constater que si vous êtes extrêmement
volontaire pour prendre un billet
d'avion et que vous avez vraiment besoin
de le faire et que vous allez taper sur
votre ordinateur
paris berlin
dix fois ou 12 fois dans un an deux
heures en essayant plusieurs compagnies
aériennes eh bien vous avez aujourd'hui
ddd vous êtes repéré et vous avez une
entente des compagnies de lyon
d'aviation pour dire celui-là il veut
vraiment aller à berlin
ce jour là et donc on augmente les
tarifs donc cette politique commerciale
agressive au détriment du consommateur
devrait être interdit ce que pour
l'instant la loi sur les données
personnelles ne permet pas donc vous
êtes toujours quand même toujours soumis
à des logiques qui sont des logiques que
contraires à la concurrence et qu'elle
devrait autoriser l'utilisation
d'internet
c'est l'heure maintenant de passer à la
partie politique de cette émission avec
notre partenaire du figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour vous interroger en art comme
accueille cette semaine arthur berda
bons joueurs tu as genre yann bonjour
marion bonjour stéphane peut nous allons
revenir ensemble ce matin sur les
manifestations qui ont eu lieu jeudi à
paris et partout en france puisque les
cheminots et les fonctionnaires sont
descendus dans la rue pour protester
contre les réformes du gouvernement
d'abord un mot sur la mobilisation selon
un comptage indépendant réalisé pour un
collectif de médias dont le figaro
c'était une première
47 1800 manifestants sont descendus dans
la rue à paris
est ce que c'est un chiffre qui vous
satisfait ou qui vous déçoit moi j étais
dans la manifestation rend enfin moi ça
me satisfait ça a été un bon faut
compter deux choses dans une
mobilisation faut compter le nombre de
grévistes et le nombre de manifestants
il y avait beaucoup de grévistes plus
que ce que la direction de la sncf avait
imaginé s'agissant des cheminots mais
aussi beaucoup dans l'éducation
nationale et dans la fonction publique
il y avait beaucoup de manifestations
alors on n'a pas de référence pour
compter avec ce système avant on avait
les chiffres de la police et des
chiffres des organisateurs avec souvent
des écarts extrêmement important voilà
il semblerait que ce soit un moyen
d'objectiver tout ça le problème c'est
qu'il va falloir qu'on ait des
références c'est une première donc on
peut pas se référencer pour moi il y
avait énormément de monde j'ai
l'habitude de faire des manifestations
j'ai mis trois heures pour aller de
bercy à la bastille en marchant et en
piétinant aussi parfois et donc non non
il y avait il y avait du monde
j'avais 20 ans qu est ce que la
manifestation de jeudi selon vous ça va
être enfin le lancement du grand
mouvement social que la gauche radicale
alternative leur poulain comme on veut
mais pas parvenus à lancer au moment de
la réforme du code du travail
bon d'abord enfin les mouvements sociaux
personne n'a de un bouton sur lequel
appuyer l'un c'est moi ce que j'ai
constaté hier ces jeux c'est une
convergence
j'ai vu des avocats des filets à côté de
fonctionnaire de préfecture puis
d'infirmières et de médecins d'hôpitaux
de cheminots enfin bref c'est ce
sentiment que ce gouvernement s'attaque
aux services publics et les services
publics dans un pays comme la france
c'est la république et que quand on
affaiblit les services publics ont
affaibli la république parce que telle
est notre histoire
telle est notre pays et elle est la
force de ce pays de 2,2 de garantir une
certaine égalité d'accès à des biens qui
sont vitaux et de absolument nécessaire
donc republic services publics
et là je crois qu'il ya un élément de
convergence très fort puisque vous étiez
dans le cortège vous l'avez dit vous
avez constaté que le parti socialiste a
été hué le pcf auquel vous appartenez a
été plutôt discret en revanche lui qui a
été acclamé hier c'était jean luc
mélenchon est ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est la
france insoumise qui captent qui
incarnent les revendications sociales du
pays selon vous que le parti socialiste
se fassent tuer
bon je trouve ça dommage pour ce qui me
concerne un bon en même temps quand on a
fait pendant cinq ans la politique
qu'ils ont fait de 2012 à 2017 il
fallait pas s'attendre non plus olivier
faur l'a dit lui même je m'attendais pas
à être aussi avec un tapis rouge
bon enfin les gens ils ont un peu de
mémoire quand même donc il va falloir
faire un peu plus de preuves de 200 sans
véritable opposition et 2 puis aussi de
son propre réflexion sur les cinq années
de françois hollande
après si vous voulez moi je faut faire
attention les gens n'ont pas envie de
récupération politique
moi j'ai aussi quand j'ai vu les
carnations pas de récupération ménard
nation ou même de cabas nation et d'un
carnet même dakar nation l'ailé
moi j'ai vu des gens qui ont envie de ce
saint carné ou de se retrouver dans aux
orgues aucun aucune formation politique
où aucun leader en particulier j'ai
surtout vu des gens qui veulent tout
faire pour être le plus nombreux
possible à résister à cette ses attaques
contre notre pays et notre république
parmi ces gens il y en a un qui fait un
peu son retour médiatique c'est olivier
besancenot l'avait pas vu depuis un
moment qu'est ce que ça peut apporter
selon vous à votre combat la présence le
retour d'olivier besancenot qui a une
personnalité médiatique connu et reconnu
d'après midi
il est revenue et parce qu'il a une
parole forte de bon sens de mon point de
vue c'est celle de l'unité voir que
quand on est face à des rouleaux
compresseurs comme celui du gouvernement
macron avec une loi tous les deux jours
essayé d'étourdir comme on est ourdi un
canard avant de l'assommer
on essaye d'étourdir le pays par une
avalanche de loi et essayer de faire
perdre le sens est bon se dire il faut
se rassembler chacun doit sortir de ces
postures un peu individuel ou partisane
c'était une voix et une direction de bon
sens olivier besancenot la porte et il a
eu raison
et je m'en félicite merci c'était un peu
merci arthur merci stéphane peu d'avoir
été notre invité cette semaine dont par
le manque d'eau merci à vous ariana
mancini et je vous rappelle que les
chaînes parlementaires sont partenaires
du sidaction on ne guérit toujours pas
du sida
seule la recherche permettra de vaincre
la maladie alors pour la soutenir fait
un don aux 110 ou sur www.sidaction.org
quant à nous nous nous retrouvons donc
la semaine prochaine pour bons parlement
être
[Musique]